up so I used to go back and play with
the guys in the summer every now and
again and Jimmy you know he was a Hustle
Man he was the kind of you know guy who
defend knocked down some Corner threes
but I didn't really think nothing else
Jimmy liked that and so the draft comes
and Jimmy get drafted 30th pick
and I say wow good for Jimmy like good
for Jimmy he made it in the NBA didn't
think he was going to be that good and
then first couple years Chicago my guys
on the bench I'll see him over there
with that weak fro and I'm like they go
my guy Jimmy but Jimmy don't talk to me
because Thibodeaux didn't like the heat
so Jimmy never talked to me you know I
see Jimmy out in L.A I don't know if
Jimmy remembered I've seen Jimmy Jimmy
out of La at like one of the parties
like for like SP weekend whatever the
case may be and Jimmy don't speak to me
at all I'm like dang that's that was my
okay whatever he choked he changed he
changed on me so it goes from me saying
damn good for Jimmy to me having to call
Jimmy at some point later on in my
career said hey man can I come to
Chicago can I play